salut c'est heu aujourd'hui on va parler
du au nord 10 passes ton ordi c'est une
nouvelle actu il est sorti il ya déjà
quelques temps on a beaucoup parlé du au
nord disent ici ailleurs à droite à
gauche sur internet et là le aux
nordistes à une toute nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui est vraiment top qui
permet d'optimiser c'est une
optimisation logiciel qui permet d'aller
plus loin au niveau de votre machine
au niveau matériel on va en parler ça
s'appelle le gti turbo
c'est vraiment super intéressant et j'en
parle
pour moi le d'autres smartphones c'est
quand même l'un des plus beaux l'un des
plus réussis à des plus abouties du
marché actuellement j'adore vraiment
vous avez plusieurs couleurs en 8 vous
avez des réflexes sont vraiment
magnifiques au nord a vraiment bien
réussi son honneur 10 par rapport aux
normes 8 par rapport au neuf
on est vraiment passé autre chose on va
vraiment la montée en puissance de nord
sur ses smartphones que ce soit en
termes de performances notamment avec le
gpu sur nos sages et vous l'expliquer
tout de suite mais tout autant au niveau
visuel et là le dos de ceux au nord 10
des chiens n'y a pas de terre vraiment
ri déchirent dans l'éventail de tous les
modèles de 2018 je me classe vraiment
dans le top 3 je trouve extrêmement beau
très bien aussi ses reflets sont
vraiment magnifiques sont vraiment
sublime et ça c'est vraiment un goût
très personnelle peut-être que certains
d'entre vous n'aimerez pas du tout pour
moi c'est franchement une superbe
réussite
ce modèle vous le connaissez pas c'est
tout nouveau modèle la couleur est juste
top c'est le fantôme green qui en 128
giga et qui est disponible dès
aujourd'hui sur amazon et d'ailleurs si
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en
bas dans la description
à moins que vous ayez vécu dans une
grotte pendant plusieurs mois le aux
nordistes on en a déjà parlé
on va se faire un rapide récapitulatif
rang de 5,84 poussée du lcd c'est une
dalle ps avec une résolution de 1280 par
1080 pixels 432 ppp il tourne son kirin
970 cadencé à 2.4 gigahertz
il a quelques gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage soit 128 giga non extensible au
niveau de la puce graphique c'est une
arm mali
j'ai 72 mt 12 il est batterie de trois
mille quatre cent millions terreur de
l'usb chiefs et du bluetooth 4.2 une
prise jack
il tourne sous android aurait eu huit
points avec la surcouche em huit points
au niveau vidéo photo à l'arrière vous
avez un double module 16 + 24 mégapixels
et à l'avant un module 24 mégapixels
tout ça a boosté à l'intelligence
artificielle d'ailleurs rester connectés
et abonnez vous puisque d'ici quelques
jours on va tester la photo et la vidéo
donc on reste connectés bon comme je
vous le disais
ya du changement chez au nord avec
l'arrivée du gpu turbo qu'est ce que le
gpu turbo le gpu turbo c'est une
optimisation logiciel va vraiment
permettre de booster votre machine c'est
donc une optimisation logiciel qui va
optimiser le matériel cette optimisation
va vous permettre deux choses
principales la toute première c'est de
gagner en autonomie puisque votre
honneur 10 va être vraiment optimisés en
termes d'affichage
il va moins consommer en termes
d'énergie va être moins énergivores vous
allez donc pouvoir l'utiliser beaucoup
plus longtemps sur des applications
beaucoup plus gourmandes et le deuxième
point et non des moindres c'est d'avoir
un regain de puissance puisque le aux
nordistes est optimisé il va donc avoir
un regain de puissance
il va donc tourner beaucoup plus vite
beaucoup mieux et ça c'est vraiment bien
alors vous allez me dire quelle
utilisation qu'est ce que je vais
pouvoir faire effectivement aux
nordistes puis puissant moins énergivore
jo pouvoir l'utiliser plus longtemps en
faire plus de choses et utiliser des
applications beaucoup plus gourmandes
oui c'est clair c'est exactement ça mais
le point je dirais le plus positif qui
va être le plus impressionnant est
vraiment ça fait partie de la politique
du nord c'est vraiment sur le gaming
pour les gamers honor s'adresse à un
public qui est quand même plutôt jeunes
un public plutôt joueur alors pas un
public très très jeune mais pas un
public de seniors
très clairement c'est pas tout la
politique de au nord donc au nord
s'adresse aux gamers et pas seulement
avec le service avec le gpu turbo et
pouvoir jouer à des jeux beaucoup plus
gourmands vous n'allez pas lui tout
sentir de latence vous n'allez pas être
pénalisés donc square a tout de suite
c'est qu'on va le vérifier on va jouer
un jeu on va faire des tests on va
regarder tout ça avec games et on va
voir le résultat ensemble sans déconner
ce contient pas ici le plus beau dos de
2018 effectivement il laisse des traces
de doigts ça on va pas se mentir c'est
pas une nouveauté les dons envers laisse
des traces de doigts néanmoins si
reflets sont juste sublime on va donc
jouer un jeu et on va regarder si tout
tombe bien avec game belge
nous voici repartis pour une session de
jeu c'est parfait
[Musique]
l'heure est à l'analyse collective en
termes de performances si vous regardez
à l'utilisation des ressources le cpu 14
% pendant 28 minutes de jeu du côté du
gpu on voit qu'une consommation qui
extrêmement me libre pendant tout le jeu
on est à moins de 20% lors d'un petit
pays entouré 45%
mais après c'est vraiment mini mini mini
l'application consomme absolument pas
c'est vraiment linéaire et ça pendant
quasiment tout le jeu au final ce quart
sont des thèses du gpu turbo est ce que
je trouve vraiment intéressant avec
cette mise à jour c'est qu'on voit que
la carte graphique est beaucoup mieux
optimisé carrément optimiser ce qui fait
que si vous allez jouer à des jeux qui
sent la mise à jour du gpu turbo serait
quand même plus gourmand en terme de
ressources que ce soit au niveau du gpu
ou du cpu
là par contre ça bouge pas très
clairement ça bouge pas c'est très
linéaire donc vous avez une consommation
moindre
qui dit consommation - en termes de
performances des batteries qui va aussi
coloniser les deux travaillent ensemble
puisque la machine est moins sollicité
la batterie va moins consommer si vous
êtes d'humeur nous allons pouvoir jouer
plus longtemps ça c'est un point qui est
quand même extrêmement positif
si vous n'êtes pas gamer si votre dada
c'est pas de jouer pendant des heures à
des jeux vous allez pouvoir faire du
multi applications sans que sa branche
utiliser des applications qui
normalement serait plus énergivores et
qu'il apprend cool ne seront pas du tout
donc quelque chose de beaucoup plus
linéaire sans votre consommation
ça c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
ça montre toute la capacité de au nord
est de huawei également parce que au
nord fait partie du groupe huawei est
une marque de huawei on va vraiment leur
capacité à faire évoluer leurs produits
à les rendre plus performants affiché
qui égale et ça c'est vraiment un très
bon point au final est ce que cette mise
à jour des gpu turbo sur le nordiste est
une réussite
oui ou non pour moi pour moi très
clairement c'est une réussite vous avez
déjà une machine qui était très bien
qu'ils tournaient bien avec le keirin
970 koupéla 4 gigas de ram ça marchait
très bien
d'un point de vue logiciel s'était déjà
optimisé mais là on va vraiment que au
nord huawei vont beaucoup plus loin
on va toutes leur force de frappe et on
va tout la pertinence de recherche
derrière et développement au niveau
logiciel pour optimiser le matériel pour
ma part si vous possédez le
je ne peux que vous recommander de faire
la mise à jour parce que vous allez
vraiment avoir un gain performances et
d'autonomie
il vous serait franchement pas déçu et
si vous recherchez un smartphone vous
êtes gamer vous voulez faire plaisir
le ordis avec le gpu turbo fera la faire
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on va
reparler du en europe d'ici quelques
jours parce que je vais vous faire un
test photo vidéo la part effectivement
de performance on parle de gainey mais
qu'en est il du côté photo vidéo on va
espérer un test à l'extérieur grandeur
nature on en profite là c'est l'été il
fait beau il ya pas mal de choses à voir
à l'extérieur dont justement on va les
faire plaisir avec ce au nordiste et on
se fera une vidéo entièrement tourné
avec leurs ordis
je vous invite donc à rester connectés
comme d'habitude a blessé des jolies
pousse à vous abonner parce que on va
continuer parler de produits
technologiques de pain produit il ya des
surprises et nouveautés qui arrivent
donc rester connectés d'ici là soyez ça
je vous embrasse et pour les foies de
bouquins
[Musique]